[Music]
in professional hypocrite news submitted
by Bart's Dutch oven oh yeah
a woman was publicly shamed by a
potential employer over a bikini picture
on her social media I actually saw this
when it came out that is such [ __ ] I
want to know that she would post that
right yeah I know
no no your place what a [ __ ] huh can I
investigate no I want to know I want to
know all right so this what this story
is it involves a 24 year old named Emily
she applied for an internship Stephen
stop it
he likes to chew gum because breast bank
if it does oh it doesn't sink because I
to go hey I chewed that's why I have
this all the time yeah Oh with that one
people who have stinky breath they can't
cover it with gum I've had and anything
with sugar adds to your stinky breath it
does but the news I've got the xylitol
suffers that that's cancerous is it I
don't know I just made that I believed
you oh I don't want to sounds like an
authority on the subject I have a bad
taste other than this helps get rid of
it I'm not a thority that [ __ ] all right
so Emily here so she applied for an
internship at a marketing company named
kick-ass mastermind which is kind of
ironic cuz they're all about like ooh
we're living on the edge sounds like
some hashtag hustle [ __ ] so what is
hashtag hustle did I miss that movement
yes you did it's a good classic - that's
where they're always on the grind and
like hash tag hustle I sleep when I
[ __ ] died what port work or play Lord
wake up in your mom's basement in Queens
wake up grind go to bed motivational
quotes all day every day but then they
don't even own a car yeah so she okay so
then this page on their Instagram
stories they post it well first let me
show you a photo of Emily very pretty
for being white super key
damn girl throwing in I know you're
gorgeous I want to know I got your dress
from okay so she ended up tweeting this
she says I was objectified earlier today
by a company because I'm a picture of me
in a bikini they claimed it made me an
unprofessional
they screenshot the photo posted on
there and so story and called me out I
am still baffled about that's being
unprofessional yet in such a manner so
use of his phone I blanked out what
happened so this is the original photo
okay they ended up posting this on her
story and it's on their story the
marketing company story Vince the story
they posted that with like her head
chopped off and then it says PS a
parenthesis because I know some of you
applicants are looking at this do not
share your social media with a potential
employer if this is the kind of content
on it I am looking for a professional
marketer not a bikini model and on the
side it says go on with your bad self
and do whatever in private but this is
not doing you any favors and finding a
professional job oh no you know what she
should have been doing that pole yeah
being in a pantsuit yes if she was
swimming in a pantsuit that would have
been professional yeah you were asking
for it wait I don't understand what's
lewd about that photo besides the fact
that it kind of made the force room dude
what because that's so they see that see
how that's a second I like that everyone
was yeah we were all with you for a
minute yeah yeah the distraction oh I'm
sorry I meant that it's appropriate
because that's what's supposed to happen
at a Vegas pool it looked like a biggest
goal is it looked like there was
hepatitis floating in there somewhere
you know so not that it was her
specifically the under boobage I'm just
saying that but how what's the different
it was there was no upper boobage what's
the difference between like cleavage in
a normal bikini and a little bit
underneath her wrong with you yeah
they're all that picture on her personal
account legalized underboob legalizing
tweeted something up like like this
sounds like oh she wears underwear
underneath her clothes so she's not
professional like that's how a
ridiculous yeah like during her old
private
she should have been wearing a business
suit in that Vegas completely drenched
yep and I don't know what this is gonna
like how this is gonna affect her
marketing position exactly that's what
everyone say I have anything company say
anything so it turns out that this
company a lot of people are commenting
and saying like hey this is really
disappointing because it seems like this
company is ran well first of all it is
ran by a woman but like most of the
company of objectify women a man would
never do something like that because
that woman was jealous yes and guys
would want her in the workforce yeah
exactly in that is a new uniform for
Friday's thank you that's what I've been
saying this whole time is guys trying to
bring girls into the workplace and help
them out and [ __ ] win together as
their secretaries in a bikini [ __ ]
weird big toilets my second that's what
I'm saying it's two more in the
workplace if I have to wear a bikini
keys my boss told me to okay well you
don't have to wear anything at all
because your boss so this is Sarah
she's like the owner she looks like
she's like Guns and Roses you see
there's never one [ __ ] [ __ ] new yes
so then this is her statement that she
wrote like the website this is all if
they have on their website it says a
statement from Sarah Kristensen of
kick-ass masterminds
in a very human moment I made an error
in judgment by posting by posting to my
Instagram stories about a job applicants
online persona to anyone watching I am a
great case study and what not to do to a
Miss Clow I apologize for my behavior I
intended you no harm I should have never
made the post to those I serve through
my business and who have trusted my
counsel many of you have been affected
by this very avoidable event there are
no words to describe how sorry I am that
you felt you have felt the consequences
of my poor decision you deserve better
and I let you down I will do my best to
earn back your trust
I've absolutely learned a lesson in this
event and while I'm not ready to
publicly address in detail
we'll let you know if or when that
changes because after her like the girl
Emily she posted on Twitter and then it
got reposted on another Twitter account
like this thing just blew up yeah people
immediately started like tearing down
the company hood like just going after
them like crazy to the point where they
deleted their LinkedIn Wow
made their Instagram private and now
like the website was down for for a
while until this statement was perfect
but what an apology that's awesome yeah
really good you never get that show
company's that was a genuine [ __ ]
apology straight to the point I'm sorry
I [ __ ] up what a great example of what
not to do no [ __ ] [ __ ] like that
was big of her yeah so did Emily get the
job no I would not if I was Emily I'd be
like I don't want it but she should have
offered it she should have offered it
yeah I would all I would hate to work
there yeah see look at what happens when
I'm in Russia I only keep the photo up
on her Instagram oh oh yeah okay well in
it she's so [ __ ] awesome too because
even on the rest of her Instagram posts
she kept posting bikini photos and
saying like up too busy being
unprofessional like she just kept like
rubbing it anything so what the branding
of this like mastermind marketing firm
like what is in the about us section and
LinkedIn it says kick-ass masterminds
matches and manages mastermind groups
for Budweiser girl yes for rebellious
business owners those who have a hunger
to call the shots in their life and
business and want to be around others in
a mastermind who crave this too they are
rebelling from the traditional way of
earning a living because oh my gosh in
corporate America they yearn for freedom
and are ballsy enough to chase after it
they are smart enough to know that they
can't go at it 100% alone probably
because they've tried and had their ass
handed to them they want other
like-minded people to have their back
when [ __ ] gets tough in their quest for
personal and money freedom kick-ass
masterminds will help you have a
breakthrough year in your business by
matching you with other like-minded
entrepreneurs in a mastermind group
that's what they're about it and they're
shaming someone for wearing a bikini
they do the exact opposite of what they
of what they say they do Yeah right
that's why is this so funny and so
ironic why don't these companies think
they're transformative [ __ ]
transfigure fine [ __ ] everything it's
funny because some of the companies that
are the most rebellious are still the
most conservative yeah yeah it's just
they want this like edgy image but it's
like you're not
that's like Hooters doing that it's a
family restaurant all right Wow and then
also people in Twitter they they dug up
on their Instagram yes hypocrisy wins
every time so there they said the irony
here is that they have a bathing-suit
photo posted on their professional
Instagram
that's [ __ ] but those are
professional bikinis they are yeah
they're not as their business occasion
so wrong yeah I could tell cuz I'm not
hard Sam that's why Sam yep I use that
as a meter that was the biggest
indicator yeah oh my god that's so
[ __ ] weird why oh why do people do
that
it just makes no sense to me it's
because they're hypocrites themselves
but they don't see anything
oh and they hate themselves so does that
mean that she's projecting her desire to
be so rebellious because she's actually
very conservative so she's created this
company man in Saudi Arabia for the same
[ __ ] yep bingo I'm entering the country
[ __ ] because you made him too
horny see the crime of making people
horny no not just people Dan but this
one is this one's girls though like
legit misogynist in this case it was
horny and you can't make other women
jealous yeah that's it take me to jail
it's a crime to be so sexy oh my god
okay we're taking to the chair to the
crazy way and firing squad
[Laughter]
she's really hot that's [ __ ] crazy
that is true they were saying that um
female celebrities influences and all
that they have double like whammies
because because of that reason because
of that whole like any Angeles mm yeah
they they have the same problem with for
the same reason so like okay so so you
face you face um extra I guess what's
the word like like hate right because
not only do you have to face other you
know guys that want to they have sexual
jealousy and they don't you know like
you because you're female or whatever
but you're also dealing with women who
don't support you because of other
reasons and insecurities and projection
so there's like from both sides right
now
yeah I need to cover up because it makes
me horny yep some religions have been
founded on such things or like guys like
you know most of us just just exist and
and you know we win because we make
people like like we're like oh you're
funny and I like to laugh at you what
nuns we're man Jesus so hot right and
guys still get horny yeah
[Music]
[Music]